unaufhaltsamen Rücken russische Panzer
vor
raketeneinschläge versetzen die Menschen
seit den frühen Morgenstunden in Angst
und Schrecken auch wenn Russland nach
wie vor bestreitet zivile Einrichtungen
unter Beschuss zu nehmen die heutigen
Bilder aus Kiew sie sprechen eine andere
Sprache er kann flüchtet andere suchen
schutzen unterirdischen U-Bahnhöfen
Männer zwischen 18 und 60 Jahren dürfen
das Land inzwischen nicht mehr verlassen
Frauen und Kinder sind bei der Flucht
nun ganz auf sich allein gestellt
ja es ist nicht weniger als ein
realitätschock da glauben wir seit 30
Jahren in Frieden und Freiheit zu leben
so als wäre das ein unumkehrbarer
Dauerzustand und dann kommt der 24
Februar 2022 und mit ihm ein Krieg den
wir so doch nur aus den
Geschichtsbüchern kannten und der uns
auch an diesem zweiten Kriegstag in Atem
hält herzlich willkommen zu diesem ZDF
Spezial
seit gestern früh also wird die Ukraine
von Russland angegriffen und glaubt an
dem ukrainischen Präsidenten selenski
sind eher und seine Familie das
vorrangige Ziel dieser Invasion dafür
müssten russische Truppen in die
Hauptstadt einrücken was laut
Beobachtern in Kiew schon bald geschehen
könnte Gerd Anhalt fast die Lage
zusammen
er ist Flugzeuglärm über dem Dorf und
dann unverhofft dass nackte Grauen des
Krieges
keiner ist mehr sicher in diesem Land
und wie Anklagen und Hilferufe
erscheinen die Handyvideos der
bedrängten hinter ihren Küchenfenstern
wenn Sie das Unbegreifliche
dokumentieren wie ein Panzer gezielt
einen PKW überrollt oder wenn russische
Kampfhubschrauber die Landstraße kreuzen
am nördlichen Stadtrand von Kiew auf dem
Weg zu Eroberung des Militärflugplatzes
host-
sehr mächtig aufeinanderprallen und im
Wohnblock nur rauchende Trümmer und
zerstörte Wohnungen und verstörte
Menschen zurückbleiben als in den frühen
Morgenstunden ein Geschoss einschlägt
der erste Kriegstag war nach
Einschätzung der Angreifer ein voller
Erfolg mit unseren Angriffen haben wir
83 landgestützte Ziele der militärischen
Infrastruktur ausgeschaltet und vier
Kampfjets einen Helikopter und vier
Drohnen der Ukraine zerstört
Ukraine in dieser Bilanz ist kein Platz
für die zivilen Opfer und die Schäden
die in den Wohnsiedlungen angerichtet
werden und deren Zahl mit jeder Stunde
des Konflikts nach oben gehen wird
es war um kurz nach vier da schrie meine
Mutter Aufwachen Aufwachen überall waren
Staub und wir hörten Schreie und die
Alarmanlagen der Autos keine Ahnung ob
das nun Artilleriebeschuss war oder eine
Rakete wir waren jedenfalls alle in
Panik holten unsere Taschen und rannten
raus
und wieder wurden die Hauptstädter vom
Sirenen Geheule aus dem Schlaf gerissen
wenn sie überhaupt ein Auge zumachen
konnten viele verbrachten die Nacht den
Einkaufspassagen oder U-Bahnhöfen wenn
sie es nicht bis in die
luftschutzbunkerschaften oder die schon
voll belegt waren oder sie ihnen so
unheimlich vorkamen
das hier ist einer der wenigen Plätze wo
man sich verstecken kann in Kiew all die
anderen sind einfach fürchterlich
Menschen die von einem Tag auf den
anderen unverschuldet und unverhofft ins
Elend von Angst und Ungewissheit
gestürzt sind deren Alltag plötzlich auf
den Kopf gestellt ist
keiner hat geglaubt dass es wirklich
Krieg gibt und selbst wenn dass sie
tatsächlich Kiew angreifen und dann ist
es doch passiert die meisten hoffen
jetzt dass alles wieder gut werden wird
und das hoffe ich auch
diese Hoffnung machen sich auch die
Einwohner die in Treppenhäusern in
fensterlosen Wirtschaftsräumen und in
Heizungskellern in der ersten
Bombennacht ihre Zuflucht fanden
uns hat um 20 nach vier eine Explosion
in der Nachbarschaft geweckt da war eine
Rakete eingeschlagen
wie ausgestorben sind die Straßen der
Hauptstadt in denen man plötzlich seines
Lebens nicht mehr sicher ist weil mit
einem Vorstoß russischer Verbände ins
Zentrum gerechnet wird
139 Todesopfer so erklärt Präsident
selenski hat der erste Kriegstag auf
ukrainischer Seite gefordert er
versprach in Kiew zu bleiben trotz
großer Gefahr
wir haben Informationen nach denen ich
für den Feind Ziel Nummer eins bin und
meine Familie ist Ziel Nummer zwei sie
wollen unser Land politisch zerstören
indem sie das Staatsoberhaupt aus dem
Wege schaffen
der Präsident bleibt aber
hunderttausende haben sich zur Flucht in
die Nachbarländer entschlossen nach
Polen zum Beispiel wo auf dem kleinen
Bahnhof der Stadt jemisel gleich hinter
der Grenze kaum noch ein Schlafplatz zu
finden war
oder zu Fuß mit allem was man hast dich
zusammenpacken konnte damit vor allem
die Kinder in Sicherheit sind hinüber
nach Ungarn oder nach Rumänien und dort
warten bis hoffentlich bald der Frieden
zurückkehrt Fluchtpunkt Europa das
versprochen hat sich zu kümmern
ich komme aus Kiel und war mit meiner
Familie in der Westukraine im Urlaub als
es passierte da haben wir beschlossen
dass wir erst mal das Land verlassen
weil wir nicht wissen wie es dort
weitergeht
und während Millionen von Ukrainern
weiter um ihre Zukunft bangen die
Angriffe überall im Lande weitergehen
sich weitere Truppen zur Verteidigung
der Hauptstadt sammeln und die Anwohner
in der Kia war Vorstadt langsam ihren
Schrecken über das abgeschossene
russische Flugzeug überwinden Park dein
russischer Panzerfahrer seine
Kampfmaschine frech an der berühmten
potjem-kinschen Treppe in Odessa für ein
Handyfoto
brutales und banales im ersten großen
Krieg des 21 jahrhunderts
ja dieses brutale Kriegsgeschehen in der
Ukraine einordnen und bewerten zu können
das wird von Stunde zu Stunde
schwieriger denn aus Sicherheitsgründen
mussten auch unsere Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die in den letzten Tagen live
berichtet haben die Hauptstadt Kiew
verlassen in der Ukraine ist aber noch
meine Kollegin Katrin Eigendorf Katrin
was bekommen sie zur Stunde mit von den
Kampfhandlungen überall im Land
ja wir sind hier in venica das ist
ungefähr 200 Kilometer südwestlich von
Kiew hier wird zwar nicht wirklich
gekämpft aber auch die Lage hier ist
sehr angespannt das heißt große
Nervosität man geht auch hier davon aus
dass möglicherweise die Russen hier in
die Stadt kommen könnten aber wenn man
sich die Lage im gesamten Land anguckt
dann steht natürlich die Hauptstadt Kiew
im Zentrum der Kämpfe es geht den Russen
darum jetzt die Macht über Kiew zu
gewinnen wie schon im Beitrag erwähnt
Präsident silenski ist das Hauptziel
denn Putins Ziel in der Ukraine ist es
diese Regierung zu entmachten und im
Prinzip hier ein marionettensystem an
Russland treues marionettensystem zu
installieren
und vor diesem Hintergrund muss man
einfach auch sehen was hier passiert das
wird nicht durch Luftangriffe alleine
gelingen putin wird mit Bodentruppen
weiter nach Kiew vordringen und wir
müssen einfach damit rechnen dass es
dazu wirklich schlimm Gefechten mit
vielen vielen Opfern kommen kann sie
sagen das Ziel Putins ist das Präsident
selensky zu stürzen und gleichzeitig
kommen heute aus Moskau gesprächssignale
Signale aus denen herausgelesen werden
kann das Putin anscheinend scheinbar
bereit ist zu Gesprächen mit der
ukrainischen Führung was halten die
Menschen was halten Sie von diesem
Vorstoß oder hält man das doch nur für
weitere Spielchen das russischen
Präsidenten
nein also Präsident selenski hat sich am
mehrfach an Putin und an die russische
Führung gewandt immer wieder mit der
Aufforderung an den Verhandlungstisch
zurückzukehren es ist ein Teil seiner
Strategie nicht nur auf den Westen zu
setzen die Bevölkerung zum Widerstand
aufzurufen Teil der Strategie ist auch
immer wieder an die
Gesprächsbereitschaft mit Putin zu
appellieren eine andere Chance gibt es
ja auch gar nicht weil die Ukraine ist
Russland militärisch komplett unterlegen
allerdings wenn man sich auf der anderen
Seite anhört mit welchen ja doch im
Prinzip Gossenjargon Putin heute die
ukrainische Führung also den Präsidenten
selbst als Drogensüchtigen Neonazi
bezeichnet hat muss man doch große
Zweifel daran haben ob Russland wirklich
verhandlungsbereit ist
Katrin Eigendorf im Südwesten der
Ukraine einen interessantes Thema dass
wir vielleicht gleich mal weiter nach
Moskau geben einstweilen vielen Dank in
die Ukraine gehen wir weiter zu für
begabten Moskau für heute kommen ja eben
doch recht widersprüchliche Signale aus
dem Kreml angeblich ist Putin zu
Verhandlungen mit der Ukraine bereit
sein Außenminister lavroff nennt
Präsident selenski gleichzeitig einen
Lügner was soll man von all dem halten
ja das sind in der Tat absolute
widersprüchliche Signale die dort
gesendet werden und dieses angebliche
Gesprächsangebot das hatte auch von
Anfang an schon so viele Haken nehmen
wir nur mal den Ort den Moskau
vorgeschlagen hat die belarussische
Hauptstadt Minsk die kann nicht als
neutraler Ort für Verhandlungen
angesehen werden schließlich ist das
russische Militär gestern unter anderem
über Belarus in die Ukraine eingedrungen
dann diese wirklich harschen Aussagen
vom russischen Außenminister der sagte
also er erkenne die Regierung in Kiew
gar nicht an die sei nicht demokratisch
gewählt sie müssen viel mehr zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden für
angebliche Verbrechen die sie an den
Menschen im Donbass begangen haben soll
also auch wenn der Kreml seine
angebliche sein angebliches
Gesprächsangebot heute Abend sogar noch
mal erneuert hat sehe ich eigentlich
keine Grundlage auf der diese
Verhandlungen dann stattfinden sollten
wenn man die Berichterstattung in den
Medien verfolgte worauf konzentrieren
die sich heute am zweiten Kriegstag
also die haben natürlich die Reden und
die Auftritte der russischen Führung
wiederholt und sie unterfüttern deren
Behauptungen mit Berichten also nehmen
wir mal ein Beispiel
angeblich das hat Putin ja auch
zwischenzeitlich mal gesagt soll es in
den ukrainischen Städten Terroristen
geben die mit Artillerie geschossen
ausgestattet sein und da zeigt das
russische Staatsfernsehen dann eben die
passenden Bilder dazu die Herkunft
dieser Bilder ist schleierhaft bzw wie
diese Bilder entstanden sind und sie
stehen im absoluten Widerspruch zu allem
was uns aus unabhängigen aus
vertrauenswürdigen Quellen erreicht in
russischen Talkshows in den
Staatsfernsehen da wird dann auch schon
mal ganz offen darüber spekuliert ob man
Präsident selenski nicht umbringen
sollte also wenn man sich das russische
Staatsfernsehen anschaut dann merkt man
dass hier das Publikum auf einen Krieg
weiter eingeschworen werden soll und
womöglich auch darauf für vorbereitet
werden soll dass die russische Führung
noch zu viel weitergehenden Maßnahmen
greifen wird das Staatsfernsehen auf das
ja die breite Bevölkerung in Russland
angewiesen ist für keinen Zweifel lässt
er der Machtapparat daran wie er mit
antikriegsdemonstranten wie wir sie
gestern gesehen haben umgehen will die
Polizei hat gestern doch mit äußerster
Härte verschiedene Protestkundgebungen
in Moskau in St Petersburg aufgelöst war
das möglicherweise schon das Ende eines
zarten zivilen Widerstands gegen
putinskrieg
das wird man natürlich sehen müssen aber
Tatsache ist das für heute erstmal keine
neuen Proteste angekündigt sind aber es
gibt schon eben einige Signale zum
Beispiel eine Online-Petition die
mittlerweile von knapp 600.000 Menschen
unterzeichnet worden ist und wo diese wo
sich eben Russinnen und Russen gegen den
Krieg aussprechen und dann hat die
kremlkritische Zeitung oder unabhängige
Zeitungen nur weil ja Gazzetta heute
aufgemacht mit einer Doppelseite in
schwarz wo sie geschrieben hat Russland
bombardiert die Ukraine sie weicht also
mit dieser Überschrift alleine schon
ganz deutlich von der Erzählung aus dem
Staatsfernsehen ab und sie hat
Solidarität gezeigt indem sie eben auf
der einen Seite den Artikel in Russisch
und auf der anderen Seite ihn auf
Ukrainisch publiziert hat die Mitri
moratow der Friedensnobelpreisträger und
Chefredakteur der novaja gazeta der hat
gesagt er glaubt ganz fest daran dass es
in Russland viele Menschen gibt die
gerne gegen diesen Krieg Aufbegehren
würden oder zumindest ihre Stimme
erheben würden und hat diese Menschen
ermuntert er hat einen Appell
veröffentlicht indem er sagte er glaube
was jetzt notwendig sei sei dass das
Volk das russische Volk sich distanziere
von der russischen Politik der
russischen Führung mehr als 1300
Demonstranten sollen festgenommen worden
sein bei den gestrigen Protesten in
Russland ihr Verbleib zur Stunde
ungewiss danke für diese Auskünfte ins
Dunkle Moskau ja es ist halb sechs in
Deutschland Mittagszeit in Washington
sechs Stunden zurück und dort hat MRT
wissen das Weiße Haus das Pentagon und
auch den Kapitol Zügel im Blick immer
also russische Truppen stehen offenbar
kurz vor Kiew für Putin signalisiert
aber plötzlich auch
Gesprächsbereitschaft um dann wiederum
der ukrainische Militär zum Putsch gegen
Präsident selenski aufzurufen welchen
Reim macht man sich auf all das in
Washington
ja das Putin unberechenbar ist und das
wird ja auch belegt durch das was in den
vergangenen Monaten gesehen haben dass
das eine aus Moskau zu hören war und das
andere dann was Vorbereitung für die
Invasion anging dann getan worden ist
aus dem Pentagon hören wir dass die
russische Offensive ein Stück weit
Momentum verloren haben soll derzeit
befinden sich nach Angaben des
amerikanischen Verteidigungsministerium
geschätzt 50.000 der eigentlich
175.000 Soldaten die Russland
aufmarschieren hat lassen befinden sich
in der Ukraine also 50.000 das bedeutet
also noch lange nicht dass das was jetzt
gerade passiert dass man ein Stück weit
zum Stillstand gekommen ist an einigen
Stellen dass das langfristig so bleiben
wird man rechnet damit dass trotz des
Widerstandes umkehrf herum Russland
weiter versuchen wird die Stadt zu
erobern und tatsächlich eben auch die
Regierung abzulösen und auch das klingt
hier sehr abstrus aus Washingtoner Sicht
das
gute ihn weiterhin behauptet es ging um
eine Entnazifizierung und man will
gerade den Präsidenten und die führenden
Leute in der Ukraine möglicherweise vor
Gericht stellen und ausgerechnet
Wladimir vlogomir silensky ist ja aus
einer jüdischen Familie die im Holocaust
Angehörige verloren hat also vor dem
Hintergrund sagt man im Weißen Haus das
ist völlig abstrus was da aus Moskau zu
hören ist denn auch Elmar könnte es ja
Putin mit seinem Gesprächsangebot es
geht da um mögliche Verhandlungen in der
belarussischen Hauptstadt Zement
durchaus ernst meinen zumindest dann
wenn er vielleicht auch seine
persönlichen Kriegsziele erreicht hat
wenn Präsident selenski in Kiew
abgesetzt ist wie weit offen würden in
dem Fall dann Amerikas diplomatische
Türen für Moskau stehen sind die oder
wären die an Bedingungen gegenüber
Moskau gebunden
ich glaube ja man bräuchte auch ein
Zeichen der dskalation in irgendeiner
Form bevor man sich zu Verhandlungen
wieder bereit erklärt gestern hat ja
amerikanische Seite sehr klar gemacht
dass Diplomatie derzeit eigentlich tot
ist dass man keinen Anlass sieht auch
mit Putin unmittelbar zu reden der
amerikanische Präsident wurde gezielt
danach gefragt wenn man sich zu
irgendwas bereit fände bräuchtest dieses
Zeichen der dskalation und dann wäre
sicherlich Minsk nicht der richtige Ort
dafür weil in der Tat Belarus nicht als
neutrales Gebiet angesehen wird hier im
Weißen Haus setzt man darauf dass es ein
klares Signal jetzt auch aus Europa gibt
man wollte eigentlich auch bei den
Sanktionen weitergehen und Russland aus
dem Swift Bankensystem ausschließen das
ist gescheitert gestern und in den
letzten Tagen an den Europäern aber man
hat die Vermutung dass sich das heute
oder in den nächsten ein zwei Tagen
ändern könnte das Stichwort Sanktionen
auf amerikanischer wie europäischer
Seite werden wir auch gleich hier
aufgreifen danke für diese Eindrücke
Washington ja die Vereinigten Staaten
haben in der Tat harte Sanktionen
beschlossen und Europa will ihnen
offenbar in nichts nachstehen gestern
Abend haben ja die 27 eu-staats- und
Regierungschefs einem umfangreichen
Sanktionspaket gegen Russland zugestimmt
die Strafmaßnahmen betreffende unter
anderem die Bereiche Energie Transport
und Finanzen
es war der wohl emotionalste Moment
dieses EU-Gipfels der ukrainische
Präsident selensky schaltete sich
gestern Abend aus Kiew in die Runde der
27 europäischen Staats- und
Regierungschefs und Chefinnen er bittet
um scharfe Sanktionen und weitere
Unterstützung die Todes sind er hat uns
gesagt dass er nicht wisse ob er noch
einmal mit uns sprechen könne das war
hart wir müssen uns im Klaren sein wie
ernst die Lage in der Ukraine ist am
Mittag dann kontert Europa neben einem
weitreichenden Sanktionspaket verhängen
die EU-Außenminister erstmals
Strafmaßnahmen gegen den russischen
Präsidenten Putin und seinen
Außenminister lavroff auf dem Befehl von
Herrn Präsident Putin sterben in diesen
Minuten in diesen Stunden seit zwei
Tagen Menschen in der Ukraine das ist
ein Bruch ein elementarer Bruch mit
nicht nur dem Völkerrecht sondern mit
den Grundlagen der internationalen
Zusammenarbeit europäische Vermögen von
Putin und lavrov sind jetzt blockiert
ein Einreiseverbot in die EU gilt jedoch
nicht man müsse ja in Zukunft vielleicht
wieder miteinander reden darauf Russland
vom internationalen Zahlungssystems
Swift auszuschließen konnten sich die
Minister nicht einigen Swift dient der
Kommunikation von Banken untereinander
ähnlich wie bei einem Telefonnetz bei
einem Ausschluss Russlands bestünde die
Gefahr dass das Land sich neue Kanäle
sucht
jetzt ist es wichtig dass wir Sanktionen
auf den Weg bringen die gezielt wirken
die gezielt auf das Machtsystem wirken
und die nicht nur groß klingen es ist
das härteste Sanktionspaket das die EU
bis jetzt zu Russland beschlossen hat es
zielt auf das System Putin
es sind ja vor allem die Osteuropäer
vormals Republiken oder Satelliten der
Sowjetunion die sich nun vor dem
hegemonialen Hunger des russischen
Präsidenten fürchten Polen auch die
baltischen Länder erwarten von dem
Bündnis also klare Kante das heißt eine
robuste eine sichtbare Verstärkung der
Ostflanke bereits gestern hatte die
Allianz ja ihre verteidigungspläne
aktiviert um schnellere
Truppenbewegungen ermöglichen zu können
um 15 Uhr oder ein bisschen später hat
ein digitaler Krisengipfel aller 30 NATO
Staats- und Regierungschefs begonnen
beobachtet von Florian Neuhann in
Brüssel und florianweg höre ist der
Gipfel zu Ende gegangen die
Pressekonferenz aber steht noch bevor so
gesehen muss man vielleicht auch ein
bisschen spekulieren darüber was denn
bei diesem Krisengipfel wohl
herausgekommen sein könnte gibt es
Anzeichen Zeichen Botschaften die sie
gehört haben
ja in der Tat wir erwarten hier
minütlich sekündlich quasi die
Pressekonferenz des
nato-generalsekretärs Jens Stoltenberg
nach Abschluss dieses videogipfels der
Staats- und Regierungschefs was wir
hören auf jeden Fall wird es natürlich
eine Erklärung geben in der die NATO
noch mal auf Ebene der Staatschefs die
Aktionen Russlands gemeinsam in den
schärfsten Worten verurteilt und man
wird auf jeden Fall auch die
Beistandsverpflichtung der NATO an alle
Mitgliedstaaten erneuern und dieses
Signal sollte man nicht unterschätzen
denn gerade die östlichen
Mitgliedstaaten sie haben es auch gerade
erwähnt die fühlen sich doch sehr
bedroht mit einer direkten Grenze zur
Ukraine oder eben zu Russland und sie
erwarten auch ein solches Signal denn
NATO und im zweiten Schritt geht es dann
darum wie die NATO sich künftig
aufstellen wird an der Ostflanke da wird
sie ja ihre Verteidigung verstärken in
den letzten Tagen haben verschiedene
Mitgliedsstaaten hier angekündigt dass
sie weitere Truppen verlegen werden in
die Ostflanke der NATO heute war es etwa
Italien dessen Premierminister Mario
Draghi weitere 1400 Soldaten der NATO
bereitstellen will und auch aus Berlin
hört man ähnliche Signale die
Bundesregierung prüft offenbar ob sie
weitere Patriots
flugabwehrraketensysteme an die
Ostflanke verschicken kann insofern es
gibt hier von vielen Seiten von vielen
Mitgliedstaaten die Bereitschaft und
auch ja den Willen dass man die
Ostflanke der NATO verstärkt und so auch
ein deutliches Signal der Abschreckung
Richtung Russland wiederum senden kann
Florian Neuhann zu den Erkenntnissen
nach dem NATO-Gipfel die Pressekonferenz
aber wird wohl erst in ein paar Minuten
beginnen mit Nato-Generalsekretär Jens
stoltenberger seden was dieser ja
kurzfristig einberufende Krieg
Krisengipfel angesichts des Krieges in
der Ukraine ja ergeben hat danke nach
Brüssel einstweilen und wir wollen beim
Thema bleiben und den Staffelstab mal
direkt weiterreichen an Bundeswehr
General aD Egon Rams ich grüße Sie ganz
herzlich
guten Abend Herr kleiner arms welche
Konsequenzen muss denn die NATO aus
ihrer Sicht ziehen um dieser neuen
Bedrohungslage an der östlichen Flanke
Rechnung zu tragen
also zunächst mal finde ich die
Durchführung dieser virtuellen
Gipfelkonferenz ausgesprochen positiv
weil sie noch mal das Signal Richtung
Russland und Wladimir Putin sendet dass
die NATO geschlossen handelt wir haben
ja auch seit gestern einige Ereignisse
dabei gehabt auch wir haben Orban der
russische Minister der Joy der
ungarische Ministerpräsident hat sich ja
mittlerweile einigen Dingen
angeschlossen bei denen er vorher nicht
so positiv aussah von daher ist dieses
Signal der Geschlossenheit ein sehr
wichtiges Signal mit Blick auf die 3400
italienischen Soldaten die an die
Ostflanke entsandt werden sollen kann
ich nur sagen das ist eine gewaltige
Leistung von Seiten Italien wofür sich
die Länder der Ostflanke wahrscheinlich
im Südbereich entsprechend bedanken
können die Prüfung der deutschen Seite
Patrick raketenflugraketen dort
hinzubringen ist auch ein guter Schritt
denn in diesem gesamten Bereich ist die
Flugabwehr ich sage das mal vorsichtig
nicht so gut ausgestattet
es steht in deutscher von deutscher
Seite auch noch zur Disposition
möglicherweise eine weitere
infanteriekompanie in den französischen
Verband in Rumänien zu entsinnen auch
dies ist ein guter Ansatz das heißt man
muss sehen wie sich die Verstärkung an
der Ostflanke auswirkt und ich darf
darauf hinweisen dass ja auch die Natur
response bereits in einer Hütte
verlegebereitschaft versetzt worden ist
und dann gibt es noch innerhalb der
heterresponse die berühmte Barry high
regis John tasforce die dann ebenfalls
auf kurzer Zeitachse zur Verfügung steht
was auch immer die NATO jetzt tut dem
die Ostflanke zu verstärken den
russischen Vormarsch in der Ukraine wird
sie ja nicht aufhalten können die
militärische Lage bleibt heute relativ
unübersichtlich und doch scheinen die
Verluste auf russischer Seite doch
größer zu sein als erwartet wir haben
gerade gehört dass so ein bisschen das
Momentum verloren gegangen ist sagt MRT
wissen die russischen Truppen sollen
nicht alle Zwischenziele erreicht haben
behauptet auch Kiew ist das auch ihr
Eindruck
also ich versuche mal eine vorsichtige
Lagebeurteilung vorsichtig aus dem
Grunde weil ein Teil dieser Meldungen
die Sie gerade erwähnt haben noch nicht
bestätigt sind aber für mich sieht die
Sache so aus dass Kiew sich und
offensichtlich zu Anfang konzentriert
hat auf eine Verteidigung gegen einen
Angriff der überwiegend von Osten
erfolgt der Angriff der aus Norden
gekommen ist und auf Kiew selber zielt
hat offensichtlich die Verteidigung bzw
die Planungen der Ukrainer etwas
zerstört oder oder in eine andere
Richtung gelenkt und wenn man heute
unter anderem auch Meldungen bekommt
dass sich hier ukrainische Panzer
mittlerweile nach Kiew bewegt haben oder
in kieft mittlerweile fahren um dann den
die Stadt Kiew nach Norden zu verlassen
dann sieht man dass man sich
offensichtlich jetzt auf die
Verteidigung gegen den Angriff aus dem
Norden konzentriert und die
Informationen die Sie gerade genannt
haben das ist offensichtlich bei den
Russen nicht so schnell vorangeht wie
man sich das vorgestellt hat liegen mir
in gleicher Form auch bleibt abzuwarten
da bin ich ganz vorsichtig wie sich
dieses in den nächsten Tagen darstellen
aber es wird offensichtlich kein
russischer Durchmarsch mehr von
Militärexperten hörte man ja seit
gestern immer wieder das vor allem im
Jahr technisch unterlegene ukrainische
Militär könnte den Russen wenig
entgegensetzen die Niederlage der
Ukraine quasi nur eine Frage der Zeit
aber vor dem Hintergrund was sie gerade
beschrieben haben könnte die Zeit nicht
auch für die Ukraine laufen zumal wenn
sich ja russische Verluste auf addieren
also nochmal mit aller Vorsicht von
meiner Seite weil ich nicht in
Spekulationen reingehen möchte ich
glaube dass die Zeit zur Zeit für die
Ukraine spielt einfach auch weil die
entsprechenden Verstärkung aus anderen
Teilen des Landes herangezogen werden
können und damit praktisch den Hauptstoß
der russischen Streitkräfte aus dem
Norden möglicherweise mit aller Vorsicht
Abstoppen können das wäre eine
Möglichkeit es gab heute auch noch
Meldungen das ist Kräfte westlich von
Kiew geben soll auch das ist eine Sache
auf die die Ukraine mit Sicherheit nicht
vorbereitet ist von daher muss man
abwarten wie sich dieses möglicherweise
dann auswirkt also alle Lage
Beurteilungen diese Richtung kann ich
wirklich nur empfehlen mit aller
Vorsicht anzusprechen und sorgfältig zu
beobachten wie die Meldung weiter
vorgehen es sieht nicht nach einem
russischen Durchmarsch aus auch wenn man
die Informationen wie sie zurecht sagen
aus der Ukraine und über das
Kampfgeschehen dort in der Tat mit
Vorsicht genießen muss weil es eben
keine gesicherten Quellen sind her haben
sich danke Ihnen wie immer für diese
Expertise vielen Dank
ja in den nächsten Tagen sollen ja 7000
amerikanische Soldaten nach Europa
aufbrechen um wie Präsident beiden ist
formuliert
nato-verbündete zu beruhigen und
Russland abzuschrecken ankommen dürften
die meisten dieser neuen Truppen in
Ramstein etwa zehn Kilometer westlich
von Kaiserslautern gelegen die Rammstein
Air Base ist mit über 8000
Militärangehörigen die personell größte
Einrichtung der amerikanischen Luftwaffe
außerhalb der USA die Air Force nutzt
diesen Standort schon seit Anfang der
1950er Jahre als europäische Drehscheibe
für fracht- und Truppentransporte und
hier starten und landen dann eben auch
regelmäßig große militärische
Transportflugzeuge mit denen wohl auch
zumindest einige der 7000 weiteren
US-Soldaten nach Deutschland kommen
werden vor Ort ist meine Kollegin
Susanne gehlharz in Ramstein
Susanne ja welche Rolle spielt die US
Airbase im Ukraine Konflikt
ja dieser
US-Luftwaffenstützpunkt spielt eine
wesentliche Rolle für die NATO in diesen
Tagen wir können ihn nicht betreten
meistens ist das nicht möglich in diesen
Tagen erst recht nicht militärisches
Sperrgebiet sagt man uns aber von hier
oben kann man sehr gut die Ausmaße des
größten US-Luftwaffenstützpunkt
außerhalb der USA sehen seit 2005 ist er
der dreh- und Angelpunkt für den
Transport von waffenausrüstung von
Personal und er soll auch genutzt werden
in den letzten Tagen hat sich hier der
Flugverkehr verstärkt es sollen auch
Transportmaschinen und Tankflugzeuge aus
Großbritannien dazu gekommen sein
Rammstein hat in den letzten Jahren in
vielen Konflikten und Kriegen eine
wesentliche Rolle gespielt zuletzt im
letzten Sommer bei der Evakuierung des
Flughafens von Kabul und auch in diesen
Tagen wird er wieder ein wichtiges
Drehkreuz sein
etwa 100 Kilometer weiter nordwestlich
von Ramstein ebenfalls noch in
Rheinland-Pfalz liegt ja der
US-Stützpunkt Spangdahlem welche
Bedeutung hat der für die militärischen
Aktivitäten der USA in Europa und
möglicherweise auch im Ukraine kriegt
da sind die
kampfjetsstationiert und auch dorthin
wurden mehrere Kampfflugzeuge verlegt in
den letzten Tagen das ist dieser
Kampfjet vom Typ F35 die sollen an der
Ostfront der NATO eingesetzt werden wir
uns die US-Airforce heute sagte und zwar
besonders im Baltikum und in Rumänien
das ist ein vorübergehende Maßnahmen hat
man mehrfach betont und natürlich
Maßnahmen die der Stärke des
Verteidigungsbündnisses dienen sollen
soweit die Einschätzungen meiner
Kollegin Susanne gehlhardt live in
Ramstein danke für diese Auskünfte
dorthin
ja es sind Worte der selbstkritiker wie
man sie nur selten hört von deutschen
Spitzenpolitikern ich bin so wütend auf
uns weil wir historisch versagt haben
twitterte die frühere
Verteidigungsministerin Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer kurz nach Beginn der
russischen Invasion man habe vergessen
dass man nur gut verhandeln könne wenn
man militäre stark sei und AKK ist nicht
mehr im Amt an der ampelregierung liegt
es nun die deutsche Außen- und
Verteidigungspolitik neu zu definieren
im Lichte eines Krieges der auch für
Deutschland ganz sicher eine Zäsur
darstellt aus Berlin Karl Hinterleitner
heute Mittag vor dem Kanzleramt Proteste
gegen den Krieg die Demonstranten sind
hauptsächlich Ukraine viele vor Ihnen
fühlen sich vom Westen im Stich gelassen
wir möchten keinen Krieg in unsere
Heimat wir möchten
actions von Deutschland actions von
Europa wir brauchen Hilfe wir bitten
nicht um Waffen wir bitten nur um starke
Sanktionen jetzt was noch muss passieren
zu dem was schon passiert ist hatte
einige hundert Meter weiter kurz zuvor
der Bundespräsident gesprochen
Frank-Walter Steinmeier brachte die
Stimmung im Land noch einmal auf den
Punkt
uns allen ist das Herz schwer in diesen
Tagen
russlands Präsident hat unter
lügnerischen Vorwänden ein Angriffskrieg
gegen die Ukraine entfesselt ich habe
elira an Präsident Putin
stoppen Sie den Wahnsinn dieses Krieges
jetzt
zugleich wächst die Sorge um die eigene
Sicherheit im Lagezentrum des
Innenministeriums rechnet man mit
Cyberangriffen aus Russland auch
kritische Infrastruktur könnte betroffen
sein meint die Ministerin also wir gehen
davon aus dass Cyberangriffe natürlich
auch ein kriegerisches Mittel sind das
wird sich in erster Linie erstmal auf
die Ukraine beziehen aber
selbstverständlich sind wir auch wachsam
und sehr aufmerksam und vorbereitet was
möglich ist Cyberangriffe auf die
Bundesrepublik betreffen und es setzt
sich die Einsicht durch das in der
Vergangenheit zu wenig für die
Landesverteidigung getan wurde der
Bundesfinanzminister kündigt an dass
jetzt zu ändern
er hatten nach dem Ende des Kalten
Krieges das Gefühl das brauchen wir
nicht mehr andere übernehmen die Lasten
etwa die Vereinigten Staaten und
Deutschland hat sie auch anderen Fragen
wie beispielsweise der Entwicklung des
Sozialstaates gewidmet und darüber ist
eine der wichtigsten staatlichen
Aufgaben die äußere Sicherheit zu
garantieren in den Hintergrund geraten
über Jahre das muss jetzt wenn es nach
mir geht korrigiert werden es ist der
zweite Tag nach der Invasion der
Bundespräsident fordert Konsequenzen
wir wollen keine Feindschaft mit dem
russischen Volk im Gegenteil aber dieses
Unrecht
kann nicht ohne deutliche Antwort
bleiben nur wie die genau aussehen
könnte weiß bisher niemand so richtig
unterdessen steht Kiew kurz vor dem Fall
ja da hatte die Bundesregierung
monatelang auf eine Eindämmung ein
eindämmen des russischen
präsidentengesetz und nun das nun führte
Wladimir Putin Krieg gegen die Ukraine
Theo Koi in Berlin was bewirkt Putins
Angriff eigentlich bei den
ampelkoalitionären
ja so ohne es überzeichnet zu wollen
aber ihr hat ein breites Umdenken
eingesetzt die russische Version hat in
Berlin eine
realpolitische Ernüchterung ausgelöst
die bittere Erkenntnisse die Zeit der
Friedensdividende die wir ja seit dem
Fall der Mauer hatten mit einem Schlag
vorbei ist selbst Angela Merkel die ja
16 Jahre lang versucht hat in russischen
Präsidenten einzudämmen sprach heute von
einer tiefgreifenden Zäsur ich glaube
man kann gesichert davon ausgehen dass
der Wehretat erhöht werden wird aber das
ist natürlich Geld das dann an anderer
Stelle fehlt und die anderen Ziele der
Ampel wie beispielsweise die große
Energiewende die sind ja finanziell
schon extrem aufwendig kurzfristig
bietet die Bundesregierung der NATO
jetzt Kräfte zur Verstärkung der
sogenannten Ostflanke an da geht es um
die Stationierung von Flugabwehrraketen
und möglicherweise auch um 150 Soldaten
und Radpanzer bleiben wir vielleicht
noch mal Theo kurz beim Wehretal im
Koalitionsvertrag fand der praktisch
fast keine Erwähnung auch nicht zwei
Prozent Ziel der Finanzminister den
haben wir gerade gehört der ist nun
dafür der Bundeswehr mehr Geld zur
Verfügung zu stellen selbst die Grünen
schließen das nicht mehr aus wie könnte
das im Zweifel finanziert werden und
dann welcher Höhe könnte man sich
vorstellen dürfte der vereta erhöht
werden also es entwickelt sich zumindest
ein Konsens das der WETA steigen muss
wir haben ja gestern alle auch den
heeresinspekteur gehört dass die
Bundeswehr mehr oder weniger blank da
steht für Zahlen scheint mir ist es noch
zu früh der Grünen Parteichef nuripur
hat heute angekündigt man werde in den
nächsten Tagen Gespräche über den
Verteidigungshaushalt führen und der
Finanzminister der ja das Geld
eigentlich zusammenhalten muss der hat
wie wir gehört haben sich schon besorgt
gezeigt dass die Bundeswehr ihrem
Auftrag nicht gerecht werden kann das zu
viel gespart wurde ein
verteidigungsexperte hier in Berlin der
bezifferte den Bedarf heute eher auf
drei bis vier Prozent des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts das scheint mir
aber schwer vorstellbar in der
Verteidigungs der liegt aktuell ja bei
ungefähr 1,5 Prozent 4 Prozent das wäre
dann doch deutlich über dem 2% zählt das
die NATO für seine Mitglieder definiert
hat vielleicht noch ein Wort zur
Energiepolitik sie haben es gerade schon
angesprochen auch da deutet sich eine
neue Sicht an zumal eben bisher eine
große Abhängigkeit von Russland Bestand
könnten da noch alte Gewissheiten wie
zum Beispiel das Ende der Atomkraft
eigentlich zum Ende des Jahres geplant
noch ins Wanken geraten nein das glaube
ich nicht erinnere Renaissance der
Atomkraft halte ich für ausgeschlossen
aber zweierlei könnte passieren erstens
wird auch die Ampel erhebliche
Flexibilität bei fossilen Energiequellen
also bei ölgas und Kohle zeigen müssen
um sich unabhängiger von Russland zu
machen und gleichzeitig wird man
versuchen die Energiewende zu
beschleunigen das heißt die viel zu hohe
Abhängigkeit von Putins
Energielieferungen die dürfte auch als
Hebel genutzt werden um die Umstellung
auf erneuerbare Energien massiv zu
beschleunigen
es ist ein Krieg der auch für die
Berliner Politik und für die Koalition
dort viele Implikationen hat und
offenbar auch eine Zeitenwende darstellt
Theo danke nach Berlin es ist ein Krieg
ja der ganz Europa angeht Deutschland
wir haben es gerade gehört aber nicht
nur weil mit Putins Zivilisationsbruch
unschuldige Menschen sterben müssen auch
weil die Folgen dieses Feldzugs bis weit
in den Westen des Kontinents reichen
werden laut Vereinten Nationen sind in
der Ukraine bereits 100.000 Menschen auf
der Flucht das könnten sogar bis zu 4
Millionen Werten heißt es sollte sich
die Situation weiter verschlechtern ist
Europa darauf vorbereitet bevor wir an
die slowakisch ukrainische Grenze
schalten Simon Pfanzelt über eine
Herausforderung die schon sehr bald auf
Deutschland und auf ganz Europa zukommen
wird
wenn Martha Schmidt jetzt Nachrichten
von ihrer Familie bekommt sind das
Nachrichten aus dem Krieg ihre Mutter
lebt in der Ukraine der Vater die
Geschwister und Martha kann ihnen nicht
helfen hier von München aus
einzigste was ich machen kann das ist ja
jetzt beten und einfach meine
Solidarität zu zeigen und mir leider
nicht noch am Wochenende waren Martas
Eltern zu Besuch in München seit gestern
schicken sie Handyvideos wie dieses der
Flughafen der Heimatstadt ist offenbar
bombardiert worden jetzt ist die Familie
auf der Flucht wir erreichen Sie heute
per Videocall in der Nähe der Grenze zu
Ungarn letzte Nacht haben sie im Auto
verbracht
diese Nacht brauchen wir unbedingt ein
bisschen Schlaf aber es gibt keine
Unterkunft nirgendwo hier alles hier ist
besetzt alles ist voll mit Flüchtlingen
und verletzten wir suchen weiter und
morgen versuchen wir wieder über die
Grenze zu kommen
vor ein paar Tagen habe ich mich noch
mit Freunden getroffen und ich hatte
noch Pläne wollte Englisch lernen ein
normales Leben führen Sport machen und
jetzt sehne ich mich nach Sicherheit und
möchte mit meinen beiden Eltern zusammen
sein
zusammenbleiben oder sich trennen diese
Frage treibt gerade viele Familien in
der Ukraine um weil Männer die in den
Krieg ziehen könnten das Land nicht mehr
verlassen dürfen keiner weiß wann man
sich wieder sieht
an den Grenzen kilometerlange Staus
tausende sind schon aus dem Land
geflüchtet innerhalb der Ukraine sollen
100.000 Menschen auf der Flucht sein im
ganzen Land steigen Sie in Züge
hauptsache weg von hier Ziel und Zukunft
ungewiss
wir wurden durch Explosionen geweckt es
ist zu gefährlich es ist hier zu nah an
der Frontlinie
wir wissen nicht wo wir am Ende ankommen
die Situation ändert sich so schnell es
ist schwer zu sagen wie wir uns fühlen
die EU hat mit allen östlichen
Mitgliedstaaten Notfallpläne erarbeitet
damit sofort Menschen aufgenommen werden
können und auch die deutschen
Bundesländer bereiten sich vor
zum einen wird es Hilfe geben für die
unmittelbaren Nachbarländer der Ukraine
zum Beispiel Rumänien und anderen und
dann wenn wir selbst eigene Kapazitäten
aufbauen aber über die Größenordnung da
kann auch im Moment nicht abschließend
entschieden werden aber wenn auf jeden
Fall unseren Beitrag leisten Martha
schmidhofft dass ihre Familie geholfen
wird aber sie hat auch Angst dass der
Kontakt abbricht die Handy-Akkus ihrer
Eltern werden Lehrer und Lehrer und sie
finden im Moment keinen Ort wo sie ihre
Telefone Laden könnten
ja zur ersten Anlaufstelle für Migranten
aus der Ukraine werden natürlich die
Länder die eine gemeinsame Grenze mit
der Ukraine haben und dazu zählt auch
die Slowakei Britta Hilpert ist in den
äußersten Osten das Landes gereist
direkt an der Grenze zur Ukraine von
dort sind es ungefähr 250 km nach
Lamberg Britta wir erreichen sie live
dort an der Grenze stehend ja wie ist
die Lage begeben sich bereits Ukraine
mit Zack und Pack über die Grenze
ja den ganzen Tag sind hier so nach und
nach immer wieder Schwünge von Frauen
und Kindern rübergekommen sie werden
dort sehr streng kontrolliert denn die
ukrainischen Männer dürfen nicht mehr
ausreißen sie müssen bleiben sie müssen
kämpfen und hier in wieschen in den
Metzger auf der slowakischen Seite
stehen dann in der Regel Verwandte oder
Freunde hier stehen noch so ein paar sie
halten Kontakt über Mobiltelefon und
bringen die Leute dann weiter ins Land
ins Innere in der Regel bleiben sie bei
Familie oder Freunden und die die nicht
wissen wohin für die stehen ja auch
Kirchenvertreter bereit um sie dann in
kirchlicher Einrichtung oder in
staatlicher Aufnahmelager zu bringen
aber es sind wohl so um die mehrere
tausend die heute über den slowakischen
Teil der ukrainischen Grenze gekommen
sind wie gesagt in der Regel nur Frauen
mit ihren Kindern und die slowakische
Regierung zeigt sich vorbereitet auf das
was da noch kommen soll
das sind Bilder die uns nachdenklich
machen und sicherlich erst gewissermaßen
der Anfang einer Flüchtlingswelle sein
dürften die uns in den nächsten Tagen
und Wochen erwartet zumal dann wenn das
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine noch viel
schlimmer wird Britta danke für diese
Eindrücke an die slowakisch-ukrainische
Grenze gerade wenn man etwas so etwas
sieht was er uns Britta Hilpert gerade
gezeigt hat dann ja dann wächst die
Bereitschaft zum Spenden wenn sie
spenden wollen dann tun Sie das bitte an
das Aktionsbündnis Katastrophenhilfe
Stichwort ZDF Nothilfe Ukraine die
IBAN-Nummer lautet
de65-100 400 600 100 400 600 alle
Informationen auch unter
spenden.zdf.de oder im zdftext auf Seite
890 dort können Sie alles noch einmal in
Ruhe nachlesen
der russische Einmarsch in der Ukraine
er hat klar weltweit Wut und Bestürzung
ausgelöst
rund um den Globus gehen Demonstranten
aus Solidarität auf die Straße wie hier
in Australien
und vor dem Weißen Haus in Washington
auch auf dem Times Square in New York
und in Argentinien
diese Demonstranten in Brasilien beten
in einem gemeinsamen Gottesdienst für
die Menschen in der Ukraine andere
bilden ein Lichtermeer der Solidarität
wie hier in Wien
in Toronto in Kanada haben sie spontan
ein ukrainisches Lied angestimmt
außerdem Leuchten Gebäude und Monumente
in den Blau-Gelben Farben der
ukrainischen Flagge vom Brandenburger
Tor in Berlin über das römische
Kolosseum bis hin zum Regierungssitz des
britischen Premiers
Street in London
ja und das ist doch zumindest ein
mutmachender Unterschied zur Euphorie
mit der Kriege im letzten Jahrhundert
oft begonnen haben jubeln bewahrhaft
niemand denn dieser Krieg wird auch wenn
Russland die Ukraine unterwerfen sollte
keinen Sieger kennen nein ausschließlich
Verlierer im friedlichen Miteinander
Europas versagt zu haben das macht uns
doch alle dazu
das war unser zdf-spezial das nächste
folgt schon um 19 Uhr und ihnen trotz
allem noch einen guten Abend auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]
bleiben Sie immer aktuell informiert im
ZDF und der ZDF heute App
ein schwerer Schicksalsschlag ich
fürchte das eine Welt für Lucy zusammen